1re confinement difficile à digérer
depuis ce dimanche israël a débuté un
troisième confinement pour deux semaines
minimum avec de nouvelles restrictions à
la clé parmi elles l'interdiction de se
déplacer à plus d'un kilomètre de son
domicile
la fermeture des frontières aux
ressortissants étrangers ou encore
l'obligation pour la plupart des
commerces de garder portes closes
coup de tonnerre donc pour les
commerçants israélien qui commençait
tout juste à sortir la tête de l'eau
j'ai une famille à nourrir comment est
ce que je peux le faire s'ils mettent
constamment place des confinement
comment est ce que je vais gagner ma vie
le coeur est brisé mon coeur est brisé
le gouvernement nous maltraite
il ya du bon et du mauvais dans tout
cela c'est une bonne chose car il faut
contenir la pandémie
il est impossible de laisser les gens
tomber malade et certainement pas de les
laisser mourir par ailleurs les
entreprises et les personnes sont en
train de s'effondrer
ils n'ont plus d'argent pour vivre il
sera très difficile de s'en remettre
lascoumes et non 1 re confinement mis en
place en pleine campagne de vaccination
ce samedi le premier ministre israélien
benyamin nétanyahou a présenté le
calendrier de vaccination qui doit
débuter cette semaine le chef du
gouvernement israélien s'est ainsi donné
un mois pour vacciner près d'un quart de
la population d'israël
selon lui cette opération est sans
précédent dans le monde au cours du
week-end j'ai dit aux dirigeants des
compagnies qui nous fournissent les
vaccins que notre but était de vacciner
elle cent cinquante mille personnes par
jour à partir du début de la semaine
prochaine ce serait un record mondial
dès que ce sera réalisée nous pourrons
au bout de 30 jours sortir du court aux
navires us et rouvrir l'économie déjà
fragilisé politiquement avec la
dissolution du parlement la semaine
dernière israël accuse le coup face au
virus ces derniers jours le pays
recensait plus de 3000 nouveaux cas de
contamination quotidien sur ce sujet le
gouvernement a été clair
le confinement pourrait être prolongée
d'un mois si ces chiffres ne repasse pas
sous la barre des 1000 cas journalier